Okay, Ghostface, will you do the honors?
Please welcome Jack Quaid.
(audience cheers)
Hello!
Hi.
Casey Becker, it's so nice to officially meet you.
Oh my gosh, it is so nice to officially meet you.
Now, I can't give any spoilers away,
but boy, it's exciting to talk to you about this movie.
You are so incredible in it.
Coming from you, that means a lot.
Thank you so much, Drew, that's insane.
Thank you, yeah we had so much fun making this movie,
and we're just really excited that it's getting,
a lot of fans seem to love it.
You know, this is for the hardcore "Scream" fans,
and we're just so excited that people finally get to see it.
And to be honest with you,
I never thought I would be in a "Scream" movie ever,
because when I was about four years old,
the original "Scream" had just come out,
I think I was trick or treating
for the very first time in my neighborhood,
and it was a big year for Ghostface.
Every other kid on that block was dressed as Ghostface,
and I remember seeing this one kid with,
and I've seen it since, it's like a Ghostface mask
that's kind of translucent, you can see through it,
and you can pump fake blood down it so it runs down,
and when I saw that for the first time,
I was like, oh, no thank you at all,
I don't want to see that ever again,
and it got me off of scary movies
and horror movies in general for years.
I didn't start watching them until I was a teenager,
and then I finally saw "Scream" and it's just so cool.
I love that it's a horror movie for horror fans.
Well, I will say,
as someone who knows the franchise so well,
and knows the fans' perspective as well,
this one does not disappoint,
and a lot of it has to do with everybody in it,
(audience cheers)
including you,
Jack, you're so good.
Thank you.
Now, Courteney and Neve and David were just here.
I've known David literally my entire life,
and apparently I'm not the only one.
You know David
Yeah.
prior to filming?
I met David when I was about six years old.
I don't remember it too well,
but I think at one point I went over
to dinner at his house somehow,
and I remember I was really, really young,
and I remember, dinner parties,
you don't really love that as a kid,
and I think someone just showed me to David's game room.
He had all these video games and cool things
that as a kid, I think I played Super Nintendo
at his house when I was like six years old.
David, I love how he-
I don't know if you saw his documentary,
his amazing documentary, "You Cannot Kill David Arquette",
but when I saw him again for this,
I was so excited and I went up to him, and I'm like-
It's really hard to compliment somebody
on a documentary about them.
I was like, "You were so good in your documentary."
Right. (laughs)
Which isn't how you-
I don't know if, you're not acting in that.
It's an odd compliment to give,
but he was like, "Thanks, I remember you
from when you were six years old in my game room."
He was so nice, and he taught us all how to paint,
he took us on hikes, he's the nicest person
I think I've ever met in my entire life.
He really is, and he is a Jack of all trades.
Yes.
You never know
what he's going to do next.
Whether it's acting and wrestling
or becoming a Bob Ross certified instructor,
he lives fully, which is so beautiful.
Yeah, he's the new Bozo the Clown now, it's amazing.
Like, I don't know what he can't do.
There's nothing he can't do.
Okay, wait, is it true
that you have some celebrity doppelgangers?
Yes, so ever since "The Boys" came out,
many people on Twitter let me know
that I look like other people who are in our industry,
and so I get a lot of,
I'm going to run through the list.
I get a lot of Rainn Wilson,
I get some Adam Brody, I get some, on my good days,
I get some Joel McHale on my good days.
It's just kind of a white guy soup
that they've put me in.
(audience laughs)
But yeah, people are not shy
about telling you exactly who you look like.
All right, so is it true
that you have a big celebrity crush?
I did, when I was like a very young kid apparently.
I kind of barely remember this,
but apparently my very first celebrity crush was Vanna White
from "Wheel of Fortune".
Apparently any time "Wheel of Fortune" was on in our house,
I would come sprinting into the room
and go up to the TV,
and I don't know if they were my first words,
but some of my first words were Vanna White.
I was so enamored with her for some reason back then.
I mean, she's amazing of course,
but yeah, that was my first.
We have a surprise for you by the way.
Oh no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Hey Jack, it's Vanna.
Oh my God!
I heard about your childhood crush
and quite honestly, I am flattered.
Even though we haven't met,
maybe we could meet one day just to say hello.
So until then, mwah.
(audience cheers)
My God, so great to meet her, oh my God.
I mean, yeah, that was wow.
Okay, I got a lot to talk about with my family.
They're going to be very, very surprised
that this happened, oh my God.
Thank you.
(audience member guffaws)
You made dreams come true today, thank you.
Well, Jack, I was wondering if I could ask you a favor.
All of your fellow "Scream" mates,
which by the way,
Yes.
why did I not come up with that before?
Hmm, anyway.
Why haven't I come up
with that before, that's amazing.
Hey #screammates.
Thank you, Drew.
We just came up with it now.
We're the originals.
#Screammates.
Yes.
We're the origin story.
For your "Scream" mates,
have each taken their phones
and screamed into it.
Yes.
Will you do it with us?
Of course I will.
(Drew squeals)
Right, I got it right here.
We ready?
Yes, here we go.
One, two, three.
(Jack screams)
Okay, yours is so cute.
(audience applauds)
I can get up there.
That's a secret talent.
That is so cutie.
Ready?
(Drew screams)
(audience applauds)
I think I--
I bow to the scream queen.
Jack Quaid, "Scream" 2022.
(audience cheers)
And guess what?
He's my fellow "Scream" mate.
Screammate!
(bright music)